on va parler des salaires ce soir avec
nos invités au ca du vendredi diane
gabrielle tremblay professeur à l'école
des sciences de l'administration
universités luc patrick poulin
présidente de randstad canada bonsoir à
tous les deux bonsoir je suis plein je
commence avec vous on a d'un côté
l'inflation qui gruge le pouvoir d'achat
des travailleurs de l'autre la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre qui leur donne levier
de négociation est ce qu'on a déjà vu un
contexte si favorable que ça aux
augmentations de salaires
je vous dirai ça fait plus de vingt et
un ans que je suis dans le domaine puis
je vous dirais que ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas vu sous un garde à 20
avant la pandémie on voyait on voyait
vraiment une rareté de main-d'oeuvre qui
se faisait sentir dans certains secteurs
mais l'eau depuis la pandémie la rareté
de main-d'oeuvre l'économie roule à
plein régime puis il ya vraiment une
inflation il ya une demande accrue bout
des dames 1 2 et malheureusement pour
les employeurs ce biais de plus en plus
difficile pour vous effectivement pour
les employeurs c'est un
enjeu un défi mais les travailleurs eux
veulent améliorer leur sort je me tourne
vers vous au jeune gabriel tang les eaux
aux états unis il ya 50 millions de
travailleurs 50 millions qui ont changé
d'emploi depuis le début de l'année leur
objectif c'est d'améliorer leur sort
négocier leurs conditions on appelle ça
la grande démission est-ce qu'on a la
même chose ici
apparemment n'a pas vu la même chose ici
au québec comme au canada d'ailleurs de
manière générale est donc bon il ya il
ya des phénomènes l'a peut-être qu'ils
sont différents clairement ici par
rapport aux états unis bien sûr les gens
sont intéressés à augmenter leurs
salaires l'inflation n'en parle beaucoup
par contre dans les recherches qu'on
fait aux portables que oui ç'a l'air
bien sûr est important mais de plus en
plus d'autres aspects comme l'autonomie
au travail à faire on voyait les données
récentes et éviter que les gens
quittaient plus tôt parce qu'en fait ils
étaient satisfaits face à leurs
gestionnaires donc parfois les
conditions travaillent qui font que les
gens vont quitter entre le télétravail
je pense que vous en avez parlé vous
même si les gens ne l'obtiennent pas
fait le travail il y en a beaucoup qui
disent bien moi je l'écouté je vais
aller chercher ailleurs donc oui les ça
c'est important mais au regard d'autres
choses c'est clair qu'il ya tout un
éventail de conditions qu'on recherche
quand on veut changer d'emploi quand on
veut améliorer notre sort évidemment les
salaires comme vous le mentionnez c'est
en haut de la liste alors dans quelle
mesure ça aiderait à combler l'on se
place du côté des entreprises da combler
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre ça au québec
d'augmenter les salaires est ce qu'on
dirait vraiment chercher plus de
candidats diane gabrielle tremblay ben
moi je ne suis pas certain je pense
qu'il risque de déplacement de la main
d'oeuvre en fait il ya 17 heures on le
sait il qui ont des difficultés
hôtellerie restauration au commerce de
détail les salaires sont assez bas en
même temps les marges de son très grand
non plus donc là m'étonnerait que les
salaires soient beaucoup augmenté et en
travaillant un peu avec les gens dans
ces milieux l'oeuvre ce que je constate
c'est que les jaunes ou des outils
j'aimerais bien connaître mon horaire un
peu plus à la vente j'aimerais avoir
moins d'horaires brisé j'aimerais avoir
plus d'autonomie dont surtout la
question des horaires dans ces milieux
là c'est très très important et je pense
que peut-être qu'on n'a plus intérêt à
regarder du côté des horaires la
conciliation vie personnelle familiale
vie professionnelle parce beaucoup de
gens regardent ces aspects là les
salaires je suis pas certaine d'avoir
qu'on puisse les augmenter autant dans
les petites entreprises est souvent pour
les petites et moyennes entreprises même
les conditions travaillent la
conciliation vie personnelle
professionnelle
c'est quelque chose que les salariés
regardent beaucoup et pour moi c'était
même un facteur d'attraction vraiment
important et même est même supérieur au
salaire si je vous entends mais dans
certains cas oui il ya certaines
enquêtes est toujours difficile parce
que là en ce moment on parle pas
énormément d'inflation donc les genres
met l'accent sur le salaire mais
beaucoup d' enquêtes ont montré que les
jeunes par exemple qui arrivent sur le
marché du travail oui ils regardent le
salaire mais regarde beaucoup d'autres
choses est ce que j'ai déjà des horaires
flexibles je serai du télétravail
pourrait avoir des longs week end il ya
vraiment beaucoup d'autres éléments est
d'ailleurs une certaine recherche en
gestion de ressources humaines les
jeunes mettaient beaucoup l'accent sur
la qualité de leurs gestionnaires et ces
données qui nous indique que les gens
par houstin à cause de leurs
gestionnaires je pense que c'est très
intéressant nous dit qu'il faut vraiment
regarder ce qui se passe dans
l'organisation et pas seulement bon
monsieur poulin droit de réplique est ce
que le salaire c'est déterminant dans
l'attractivité d'une entreprise la dame
tant pis je sais pas s'il a lui même où
j'étudie des études visant auprès
d'environ 7000 canadiens canadiennes
chaque année est l'élément du
néerlandais -
québec et canada on va vers la première
restait c'est vraiment sa mère qui était
chargé les gens parcourent ou est-ce que
je suis d'accord avec madame cadets
c'est vraiment il ya plus que ça là il
ya plus que sévère les conditions de
travail dans lesquelles les gens
travaillent les possibilités
d'avancement apprend aussi une grosse
différence au niveau déjà pu dire aux
côtés pour comprendre l'aspect
aujourd'hui la réalité du travail à
distance au télétravail est devenu un
élément il paraît important lorsque les
gens vont garder par la possibilité
lorsque c'est possible de le faire les
gens vont regarder ce facteur le
convoyait doivent donc le télétravail
reste hyper important pour les
entreprises
après on peut mais
[Musique]
dans les enquêtes générales mais on voit
d'ailleurs pour québec et en
colombie-britannique en général les
travailleurs encore plus d'importance
justement à leur temps à leur vie
professionnelle nous on avait des
enquêtes qui indiquait que les gens
seraient prêts à quitter un emploi bon
évidemment c'est un groupe particulier
ceux des personnes qui ont des
responsabilités familiales soient des
enfants ou des parents j'ai donc pour
des motifs de conciliation les gens sont
prêts à bouger donc c'est ça je dis pas
que le salaire est pas important mais je
dis qu'il faut nuancer ça dépend des
milieux ça dépend des groupes et tout ça
il ya vraiment rien mais mais mais ce
qui est clair monsieur poulin c'est que
il y à des entreprises qui se font
demander par leurs employés des salaires
plus élevés on a une inflation qui est à
plus de 5% on veut des augmentations de
salaires plus substantiel ça mais les
entreprises dans quelle position serait
ce que est ce qu'ils sont en mesure
justement c'est ça l'enjeu d'offrir ces
conditions là
certaines entreprises le sont mais
malheureusement on sait ça quand on veut
justement au commerce de détail tout et
hôtellerie restauration il ya une
pression énorme kiss kiss kerry c'est
que ces entreprises de sont occupés lors
d'opérations vous avez donc là crie ça
crée une immense pression c'est là qu'on
demande aux employeurs plus possible d
essayer d'offrir aux justement que le
savais avant les conditions de travail
aujourd'hui on voit que les gens
qu'est-ce qu'on peut combler comment on
peut combler justement ce manque une
bosse à l'arrière on ne peut pas offrir
il ya plein d'autres ressources étaient
donc moyens justement qu'on peut être
créé pour les chercheurs d'emploi madame
tremblay j'ai une question pour vous un
travailleur qui observe la situation en
ce moment se dit mon entreprise il
manque d'employés ils sont prêts à
accorder peut-être à être plus souple
pour accommoder ceux qui sont déjà là et
que qu'est ce que je vaux est ce que ça
vaut la peine de négocier et jusqu'où on
va si on veut améliorer ses conditions
auprès de son employeur
bah je pense que les personnes peuvent
toujours effectivement négocié en même
temps il faut voir que dans la plupart
ont la plupart 40% nos milieux de
travail au québec sont syndiqués donc
avec mention collective des grègues
malgré ça c'est vrai que à l'intérieur
de ces règles là les classifications il
ya certaines personnes d'ailleurs je
dirais que les hommes sont généralement
meilleurs pour négocier ils ont tendance
à demander davantage les femmes
attendent donc d'un certain d'avoir
toutes les compétences avant d'oser
demander une augmentation donc on va
vraiment des différences de ce côté là
alors est ce que oui les gens peuvent
demander c'est possible mais j'aurais
tendance à dire qu'en ce moment que fait
plus facile à cause de tout ce discours
sur l'inflation de demander des
augmentations salariales mais c'est
peut-être aussi le bon moment pour
retenir les gens c'est peut-être le bon
moment de dire au patron moi si vous
voulez que je reste à moyen et à long
terme il ya des choses qui m'intéressent
comme le télétravail l'étang réflexive
la semaine de quatre jours 28 ans de ce
type là les horaires plus régulier dans
tous les secteurs dont on parle du
service là par exemple l'hôtellerie la
restauration les gens aimeraient
vraiment avoir des horaires de connu à
l'avancé des plus réguliers donc je
pense que des choses comme ceux qui sont
négociables
et pour les entreprises je vais terminer
là dessus monsieur poulin il ya beaucoup
de pression des négociations collectives
recrutement et ans et pénurie est ce que
les employeurs ont d'autres choix que
d'accorder aux
une partie de ce que demandent les
travailleurs
ouais ce qu'ils firent un petit peu plus
difficile pour les entreprises
présentement c'est que l'inflation étant
très élevé de la tendance des
employés s'est demandé justement une
augmentation selon l'inflation qui
présente actuellement mais le problème
qu'on a présentement si on sait pas
combien de temps allez vous maintenir à
ce niveau l'ouest il s'amène pression
encore plus énorme si je dirais sur les
employeurs autant à court terme même si
à long terme le document a fait dire les
salaires significativement sa toujours
beaucoup sur la propre stand des amis
c'était une excellente réflexion dans ce
contexte particulier pour le marché du
travail à tous les deux jours merci
beaucoup je vous souhaite une belle fin
de semaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit